[Music]
this kid puts on quite a
show I have eyes on the target he does
not look all that
threatening looks can be deceiving your
highness are you sure you do not want
any backup n I'm great with
[Music]
kids you thought the story was
over but it was only just
beginning I don't do
sequels
normally but things have gotten a little
[Music]
twisted in the
Multiverse
who is this handsome
[Music]
dog
I've been looking for
you for a long time time time time time
time just be
careful I don't think I can bear to Nar
what might happen
next Darcy we got a code red The
Avengers tower has been overtaken on
Christmas what is this CAU air no wait
Under Siege no no no that's not it hey
John mlan
[Music]
Focus